il
[Rires]
[Musique]
ya deux mois
[Applaudissements]
où est la route de
vous avez eu avec un politique pour
abattre tous les mois avec rachida dati
alors franchement voilà je pense qu'en
politique on n'est pas obligé de
s'agresser voyez je pense que
normalement des gens non malement
constitué peuvent dire je suis d'accord
avec ça pas d'accord avec ça tout faire
pour que ce soit son avis qui
l'emportent mais on n'est pas obligé de
la jouer comme dans une cour de récré
avec elle c'est quand même la cour de
récré tous les moins donc c'est tendu
mais bon c'est comme ça ça vaudra
peut-être plus haut un jour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un jour j'ai déjeuné avec jean-paul
tapis et johnny et j'aurais dit écoutez
les gars j'ai le sentiment déjeuner avec
la france la france du talent la france
du système d ouanna et au bout de cinq
minutes qui t'a piqué avait toujours le
dernier mot et est en train d'expliquer
à jean-paul comment il fallait jouer la
comédie à john et comment il fallait
chanter et à - comment il fallait que je
tourne et il avait raison voilà donc si
vous voulez quand on a la chance de
rencontrer comme jacques brel enfin la
liste j'ai eu la chance d'en montre des
gens merveilleux merveilleux et je me
suis pas gêné pour me nourrir de ce
qu'il m'apportait johnny me manque
jean-paul me manque berne armements